[Music]
I don't have any kids I don't have kids
uh but doesn't it kind of doesn't it
kind of feel like I
do doesn't this face have a couple kids
you know what I mean my whole life I've
always had that energy of like a dorky
like a dorky dad had a barbecue just
like fresa that
guy singing hip-hop wrong to children
like if you like it then you shouldn't
put your feet on it
hey Devon seriously pal the ottoman the
ottoman's decorative let's get those
kicks out of there
Devon thanks buddy thanks so much I
would like to get married and have some
kids someday but one of my big fears is
to becoming like a typical sitcom
husband you know what I'm talking about
some terrified
slob in the basement and his boxers just
sneaking a predinner hogy I mean like I
have a meatball sub just like oh baby
I can't wait to get my mouth all over
you and my wife Pops in all brassy like
well I knew he wasn't talking about
me huge Applause opening credits to my
sitcom unfulfilled
life but I think my biggest fear in life
is becoming a sad dad you know what I'm
talking about just hoping and praying
that his family doesn't talk to
him you know I'm talking about sad dad
just like that's a good day your family
didn't talk to you and the problem is I
feel like a lot of my friends have sad
dads they're like that but they weren't
always that way I got a big heart for
dads they didn't used to be sad they
used to be cool they had to be that's
how they got your
mom think about it your mom is great
she's not going to marry some mope
wearing a free t-shirt his bank gave
him just like if it's okay this Saturday
I'm going to trim the aelas Linda it's
not happening your dad was cool you know
this we've all seen the photos those
yellowed out photos in his shoe box in
his glory chest of your dad in the 70s
he had huge sideburns like pizza sliced
collar opening beers on his belt buckle
he could dance over to your mom in a bar
flip up a coaster catch it and be like
hey I'm
Jean he was awesome and your mom was
like Rainforest Cafe table for one you
know what I
mean but then your dad has a kid and the
dad kind of participates in his own
destruction you know what I'm talking
about he has a kid then he's not really
needed you know what I'm saying get out
of the way he's like the dad's the part
of the Space Shuttle that falls off as
the
rest as the rest of it leaves to the
atmosphere I feel you pulling away but
you it's true it's true it's a problem
the woman who falls in love with Jean
makes a baby with Jean then she has a
baby that's half Jean and half her so
beat it
Jean you got a baby now it's like the
new iPhone you can't compete with that
it's got all the giggling and cool and
cute apps and the dad's like an old
landline rotary phone like but I still
ring a
dingding you've been replaced Jean
scram but don't get me wrong I got a big
heart I got a big heart for sad dads if
I could start a charity for any group
I'm not kidding any group it would be to
help the sad dads I'd love it just a
camp it's most just like a big open
field they can run around like idiot
dogs mounds of gape they're all wearing
Indiana Jones hats just blasting Bob
Seager out of megaphones like the yard
scene in sha Shank Redemption it's like
and for one brief moment every dad felt
[Applause]
[Music]
free